what's up guys it's gary vaynerchuk for
garyvaynerchuk.com i know i'm in my wine
library uh
setting so i'm sorry i'm about to tape
an episode but uh
i just decided to pump out a quick video
i have been a little bit away from the
camera on these for a little while but
something hit me today i'm trying to
keep these you know i'm not trying to
talk for a sake of talking
which is hard for me um but i want to
really bring
content and value when i do these videos
and it kind of gets to the point of what
i want to talk about today
i'm doing more and more consulting aj
and i are getting very close to
launching vaynermedia
and something interesting i brought up
today at a at a sit down
gary how do you break through the noise
now you know you know what's happening
guys
people are starting to understand how to
use facebook and twitter and tumblr and
youtube and viddler and all these
different tools
you know it's going to get more
competitive you know and that's what
happens
and so people are saying how do you cut
through the noise brand's like well how
do we make what we do
become relevant buzzworthy viral it's
ridiculous anyway
here is how do good
stuff here's the funny thing now now
that everybody's understanding
we're done with that age ma you remember
when people like first started building
websites and
all those guys running around that new
html we're charging like eighty thousand
dollars to build a bull crap
website clearly somebody bought one for
wine library 97 wasn't that much money
but so all these social media experts
running around and making some side cash
making some bank
but really have never built anything or
know how to execute
so yeah no kidding you need a twitter
page
no kidding you need a facebook fan page
no kidding you need to be talking in
this world
there's a shitload of customers in there
but here's the difference
who's got the chops just because
everybody now
knows how to play baseball doesn't mean
you draft them
to the major leagues so what the
difference maker is going to be now
i'm sorry to say is the people that come
up with good ideas
and execute and understand how to move
the friggin
needle that's how you break through the
noise cause everybody's coming
and everybody's playing but everybody
has the ability to play the piano
and not everybody is billy joel